today on the Matt Walsh show on this st.
Patrick's Day a very strange very
strange st. Patrick's Day in many ways
everything is shutting down they're even
shutting down the liquor stores on st.
Patrick's Day which is sacrilege but
with everything shutting down it's it's
expected that there will be a huge hit
to the economy of course and today I
want to ask the question why should it
be so harmful to our society and our
economy that people are staying home
spending time with their families
spending time with their kids cooking
their own meals educating their own kids
and so on it is harmful to our economy
yes I don't deny that but isn't that
perhaps an indication that there is a
there's a fundamental problem with the
way that our system is set up that those
sorts of very healthy activities have to
be discouraged so we'll talk about that
also five headlines including Tom Brady
leaving New England to deflate footballs
elsewhere in the country and Bernie
supporters are complaining because
that's what they do best in this this
case they're complaining about voter
suppression saying that voter
suppression is what has caused Bernie
Sanders to not do so well in the
primaries but what is voter suppression
is it actually happening and if it is
actually happening is it really a bad
thing I say no it's not but we'll
discuss that today on the Matt Walsh
show all of that coming up but first
let's talk about our dear friends over
at Rock Auto you know cars cars these
days are more complicated than they've
ever been and that means what that means
is that there's more it's like in your
phone it used to be a phone was just a
thing you pick up and you use it to talk
to somebody else that used to be all the
phone could do kids back in the day
that's what it was well the great thing
about that is that there were fewer
things that could break in your phone
because it all it did was the one thing
sort of like cars now there's so many
things going on so many elements to them
that there are many things that can
break and and then what do you do when
something breaks well you go to
rockauto.com it's so much easier than
walking into a store and having someone
demand quick answers to things like is
your Odyssey in LX or an e^x and things
like that you might not know the answer
to right off the top of your head and
then you look stupid as well on top of
it and that's no good
that's why you would want to go to
rockauto.com the catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate all your
questions are answered everything is
easy enough for even an idiot like
myself to be able to navigate
rockauto.com is everything you need from
engine control
modules and brake parts the tail lamps
whatever you need they have it when you
go to rock Auto comm rockauto.com is a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right Walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
alright
so there's no question that the steps
being taken by the federal and state
authorities right now to contain the
corona virus our extraordinary schools
are closed businesses are shut down now
the federal government has issued
guidelines calling for everybody in the
country to stay inside as much as they
can avoid gatherings of over 10 people
for the next 15 days at least we'll talk
more about that in the headline section
and it may well be true that these
measures will have a devastating effect
on the economy for years to come
it may also be true that they're
necessary to prevent a catastrophic loss
of light life it may be true that our
choice right now
is between potentially destroying our
economic system or potentially
destroying our health care system
because it's not just about the
mortality rate it's also a matter of the
capacities of our hospitals if everybody
becomes infected in one big mass and
then you've got a 10% hospitalization
rate where are those people going to go
you know it could it could lead to the
breakdown of the healthcare system like
we're seeing in Italy and other places
so all of these things are being weighed
whatever the case and however we feel
about it
president Trump has indicated that it
may actually be longer than 15 days much
longer before things can return to
normal but here's a question that I
don't see very many people asking and
that is this should everything return to
normal do we actually want things to
return to normal now in order to answer
that question I think we have to first
figure out why the temporary closure of
schools and restaurants and other
businesses has the potential to cause
such havoc in the first place for most
of us I think maybe to someone who's an
alien from outer space who sees this
going on and sees that people have to
stay inside for a few weeks and then if
they were told that this the
this this alone is going to destroy
society and destroy the economy it might
not be so obvious why that should be the
case now for most of us the the self
quarantine being observed across the
country and including in my own house
involves what it involves in some places
it's more more extreme than this but for
most of us it involves basically
spending more time with our families
making fewer unnecessary purchases
teaching our kids at home rather than
sending them off to government buildings
for the majority of the day eating
eating meals that we cook in our kitchen
rather than eating fast food now these
practices it is feared will wreak untold
destruction but these practices are also
objectively good and healthy and while
they have the potential to ravage our
economy they also have the potential to
make people happier and and and and to
give them more meaningful lives now
perhaps it's worth considering whether
it is good that good things like
frugality and self-sufficiency should be
so bad for our country and and if it's
not good that good things are bad now
then maybe we should next consider
whether there is a better way to set up
a society a way that will not cause us
to break out into hives and panic at the
thought of millions of families eating
dinner in their own dining rooms because
that's what's going on right now people
are saying well we can't have all these
people eating at home the restaurants
will go down as the unemployment which
is true I'm not minimizing the potential
human cost that might be felt here
people will lose their jobs working
parents will have to quit their jobs or
spend exorbitant amounts of money of
their you know exorbitant amounts of
their income which they really need
right now especially now on daycare to
accommodate the children who are no
longer being going to school all day the
businesses will close nobody would
suggest that these things are in and of
themselves anything less than terrible
hardships nobody's saying that these
things in and of themselves are good but
these hardships this is my point these
hardships are not ultimately the result
of a virus or of a government shutdown
bottom there the result of the way that
we have chosen to structure society our
economy our lifestyles are centered
around and have been for a long time but
not have not always been throughout
human history but for us have been for a
long time structured around centered
around dependent upon people buying lots
of stuff
wasting almost every penny they earn as
soon as they earn it the vast majority
of Americans according to recent study I
read the vast majority of Americans
spend you know about 90% of their
paycheck almost as soon as they get it
but that's we need to do that in order
for the economy to work so it's centered
around that wasting all your money
sending your kids off to giant
facilities to be taught by government
employees not being self-sufficient not
spending very much time at home for the
system to work it is imperative that
those who do radical things like save
money cook meals from scratch even grow
and raise their own food educate their
own children it is imperative that they
remain in a small minority because if
suddenly everybody starts doing those
kinds of things or most of those things
the system can't sustain itself and
that's what we're facing right now is
that suddenly everybody's doing that all
at once and the system can't sustain
itself what does that tell you about the
system I think when this is all past us
well you know we're going to be urged to
run out and save the system by spending
by going on spending sprees at Target
and Best Buy in gorging ourselves on
restaurant food and fast food and
shoving our kids back into their chairs
behind their desks in their classrooms
and the government buildings with 32
other students in the same classroom
assuring mother's back into the
workforce so that they can fulfill their
sacred duties as cogs in the economic
machine and basically reverting back to
a state of helplessness and independence
as a people now after a while it will be
hoped things will level off things will
stabilize that is until there's another
MIT national emergency that we will
again be totally unprepared for an
ill-equipped to handle because we refuse
to make any adjustments to the way of
life that left us so vulnerable and
panic prone in the first place what if
there's another way of living well we
know there's other ways of living the
way we live now is modern it's new it
hasn't always been this way it doesn't
always have to be this way and just and
I shouldn't have to stipulate this but I
feel like I have to this is not a pitch
for socialism okay this is that it's not
like there are only two options
socialism or our consumerist culture
those are not the only two options
there's a lot of other options this is
not a pitch for socialism at all that is
manifestly the wrong answer but what if
there's is another way besides what the
way we live now and I don't say this
just because of the coronavirus it's not
like the coronavirus happened and all of
a sudden I'm rethinking the way society
is structured I've always been saying
this now our inability to fend for
ourselves in a time of crisis is a
pretty big concern I see people online
worried you know that especially young
people are practically going to starve
to death because they can't order out or
they can't go to a restaurant and I
understand the concern I don't think
they're actually gonna starve but I
understand because there are a lot of
young people especially you just don't
know had the idea of them making their
own meals for an extended period of time
is just bewildering to them they can't
even imagine doing it but I'd be saying
this regardless of any pandemic because
it seems like our sky high rates of
suicide drug abuse depression the fact
that we spend so many hours of each day
ten hours a day I think the latest study
says mindlessly staring at glowing
screens rather than living a real human
life all of these are indications that
the current system may make us into
relatively comfortable and wealthy
people but it is not making us into
happy and well-adjusted and
well-prepared people so maybe this
crisis can be a catalyst for fundamental
changes to the way that we we
how we prioritize things and those
changes of course would have to be
gradual but I think they'd be worth it
and if we set out to make them we might
find that the next time we have to stay
in our homes for a few weeks we don't
have to be so panicked about it this is
Minh
the way that our free market economy
works is that it is entirely consumerist
that you your most important duty is to
be a consumer and to buy stuff remember
after 9/11 a lot of people were making
fun of George Bush because he came out
and he said look here's the thing you
can do go out and buy stuff and in fact
he said that several times throughout
his presidency that was a that was a
common theme he went back to go buy
stuff well it does seem pretty absurd
that in a national emergency you're
saying our our greatest duty right now
as Americans is just to go buy stuff
well yeah that's at least that's what
the way the system works now that's
that's your it's probably your most
important duty at least to keep as far
as the economy is concerned as far as
our system is concerned the most
important thing you do is just buy stuff
on Black Friday all the people running
out the hordes trampling each other for
for consumer electronics they're
patriots there you're getting there
keeping these things going it doesn't
have to be that way where we have to be
dependent no self-sufficiency send our
kids out of the home you know depending
on government for education depending on
the marketplace for everything we could
possibly ever need because we can't make
or create or do anything ourselves
doesn't have to be that doesn't that
does not have to be the way a
free-market economy works it is the way
ours works doesn't have to be so maybe
that's worth rethinking
well moving on we'll get to headlines in
just a second but you know as we get
into spring and it's a very very strange
sort of transition into spring now but a
lot of people still doing spring clean
cleaning and going through and getting
rid of old things well you know part of
the problem is at least with especially
with my wife getting rid of old things
can be very difficult for it's for me
too I'm we're both pack rats but for her
it could be hard because things have
sentimental value she doesn't want to
get rid of that she doesn't want to get
rid of this
that's what legacy box can really help
out legacy box is a way for you to
easily and affordably digitally preserve
your past it's so easy you just pack it
up and send it over and then receive
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive a DVD or on the cloud
whatever it is whatever it is you have
you know old VHS tapes or DVDs that are
scratched photographs you know whatever
it is you have and we've we've already
done this we had a whole box of old old
things old memories that were preserved
in ways that we're certainly not the
most efficient and also not not easily
accessible so we sent it over to legacy
box and we got this wonderful package
back in it's um it's it's you know it's
it's a really easy process to do as well
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
has helped over 750,000 families
digitally preserve their past and you
can do this too you can get started
preserving your past they go to legacy
box comm slash Walsh to get an
incredible 40 percent off your first
order it's a hell of a deal but today to
take advantage of this exclusive offer
send in when you're ready so you want to
go today
get get get the offer and then when
you're ready you can send in what you
need to go to legacy box comm slash
Walsh say 40% off full supplies last
that's legacy box comm slash Walsh okay
going to headlines number one the White
House has already referenced has already
as I already referenced has has issued
new guidelines recommending that people
stay home as much as possible for 15
days avoid restaurants avoid bars avoid
gatherings of over 10 people so you
can't have any more than 10 people in a
crowd so fortunately for the Biden
campaign they've already said that this
means they can continue with their
rallies they're gonna be safe it also
means that I can proceed with my
birthday party as plan
because I'm a loser that's the joke if
you didn't get it and it's not really a
joke but there are still as far as I can
tell some serious questions like what
happens after the 15 days are up
you know Trump said this thing could
last until July or later
if the virus is still spreading rapidly
or even more rapidly in 15 days is the
quarantine extended I think the answer
right now is that nobody really knows
because nobody knows exactly what's
gonna happen we're in uncharted
territory
at least at least in our experience as
modern Americans this is uncharted
territory by the way I was also thinking
this 10-person limit is a huge blow to
Mormon Catholic and Orthodox Jewish
families you know because you have way
more than ten people in those houses so
some tough decisions will have to be
made and I mean I think every family has
to decide on your own maybe you draw
straws to figure out who has to go stay
in the shed in my family we already do
that once a week just a fun tradition
but something that maybe more families
will have to think about number two it
was announced that all liquor stores in
Pennsylvania will closed indefinitely on
st. Patrick's Day they're closing liquor
stores on st. Patrick's Day which is a
mortal sin literal sacrilege and and I
have to say I don't get this one liquor
stores are not places where large groups
gather for periods of time in fact most
liquor stores you go into there's like a
couple of people there it's nights
unless it's a special 12 like st.
Patrick's Day but aside from petrin
special occasions you know it's not like
in most liquor stores there's hundreds
of people all packed in there so you
come in you buy what you want and you
leave why would we need to close a place
like that this seems to be adding
unnecessary hardship and I'm not just
talking about hardship for people like
myself I want to have access to bourbon
but more importantly hardship for the
people that work at these places you're
shutting them down it seems like for no
reason number three Mayor Bill DeBlasio
of New York in the midst of all the
shutdowns and social social dissonant
distancing still went to the gym
yesterday to the that believes the Weiss
YMCA as the common folk are told not to
do that I guess bill figured well I'm
not common folk I'm the mayor
I'm important and he was asked about it
on CNN today on a personal note I want
to ask you how you're coping you went to
the gym yesterday and Twitter lost its
mind I don't get it but we'll move on
with our lives of gyms are all closed
now Alison yes I know is there any sense
that you were late personally to get
your arms around what the sacrifices no
everyone is gonna have to make sacrifice
but as our health commissioner said
yesterday people still are in new ways
are gonna have to get exercised whatever
scenario we're going to tell people how
to stay healthy it may be a walk it may
be a jog but obviously socially
distanced until unless we get to the
point of literally ordering everyone
indoors so this is going in stages
somehow people are gonna have to stay
healthy and sane through this and it's
going to take a lot of improvisation for
sure Mayor Bill DeBlasio we really
appreciate all the information we always
like seeing you in studio thanks so much
thanks so much houses really held his
speed to the fire didn't she well done
CNN I mean you you really you you made
him you you held him accountable there
didn't you build Bill DeBlasio is and
this is kind of a side note but he's one
of those guys who to me just seems
unappealing and viscerally unlikable in
every way he's the kind of guy who gets
on the elevator with you and you're
immediately like oh geez man this guy
just based on just for no particular
reason just something about him his
demeanor his aura his essence which
makes you wonder how a man like this
ever got elected how could anyone have
ever seen much less millions of people
seen this guy
and listened to him and thought I need
to vote for that that's my guy I I am
going to the polls for that guy and it
just once again supports my contention
that too many people vote too many
people have the right to vote the
franchise needs to be drastically
limited and reduced and millions of
people need to have their voting rights
taken away bill de blasio
his existence as a public official as an
elected representative as an elected
mayor
I think proves my point there and that
is my totally sincere and an ironic
position by the way I really do believe
that and we'll talk more about that in
just a second number four
NBCUniversal has announced that four
movies currently in theaters will be
released for home viewing early so I
think they're coming out of fact this
weekend these are movie these are movies
that are in theaters right now the hunt
the Invisible Man and Emma are all
coming out on will be available on your
TV I think this is another example
another way that society is probably
gonna be permanently changed because of
this crisis and this is a smaller thing
though not entirely insignificant but
after Universal releases these movies
and they'll be available for 20 bucks
for rent I'm guessing they're gonna make
a lot of money off of them and more
studios are gonna start doing it and
then it's hard for me to see how these
studios were revert back to the old way
the traditional way the way that's
they've been doing it for decades once
all this has passed because I think
they're gonna discover that they make a
lot more money this way and I know for
me maybe I'm imagining not alone in this
but there are many times when a movie
comes out I see a preview and I think
that looks kind of interesting I I'd
watch that but I can't get to the
theater because we can't find a
babysitter or I just don't feel like
going to the theater so I don't watch it
now when it finally comes out months
later I've already lost interest now if
that movie was available the day it came
out for me to watch at home I probably
would have spent the money on the movie
and I think there probably a lot of
people in that boat so we'll see what
happens going forward number 5 finally
Tom Brady announced today that he's
leaving the Patriots after what 20
seasons he's going off somewhere else
he'll be leaving and playing elsewhere
no word yet on whether he'll bring his
own spy cameras and deflated footballs
or if they'll provide those for him
probably they work that out in the
contractual phase I'm not sure and I
guess now's a good time to go back and
as we remember Tom Brady in his career I
think now is a good time to go back and
remember there's a great moment a
classic moment his last official pass as
a patriot this will live on forever this
is the his last official act and passed
as a patriot in a Patriots uniform in
the playoffs let's go back and remember
how that went to end
the two-game togetherness yes i meanit's
will never see this run again Jim
Rainey's pass it's intercepted in return
for a touchdown by Logan Ryan the former
Patriots the memories what great
memories I actually like Tom Brady I'm
uh you know I I'm just being a jerk it's
my way
it's how I it's how I show I care now
we'll get to you a very important daily
cancellation but before we do I want to
tell you about paint your life this I
really can't recommend this highly
enough if you haven't done paint your
life I I think it's you should at least
go to the website and check it out I
think it's a great thing and what you do
and we did this as well we found one of
our favorite photos of the kids send it
over to paint your life and they created
out of that a work of art a beautiful
painting we have it hanging in our
living room and you know every time
someone comes in without fail they stop
and they ask about the painting and
usually I'll start by telling them that
I painted it and then if they if they
buy that I'll just go with it so sorry
paint your life I take away the
promotional opportunities they're
usually they don't buy and then I'll
admit that it was from paying your life
if you want to get a truly meaningful
gift you've got to try paint your life
dot-com
I have an original painting of yourself
your children family a special place a
cherished pet whatever it is you go you
sent it to them they they create out of
it a true painting at a price you can
afford and this is done by hand this is
not some computer gimmick this isn't
some Photoshop thing they do it by hand
they send it back to you and here's
another thing I really like about paint
your life comm is that they're very
responsive through the process of
painting your picture for you they're
gonna ask you they're gonna send you
updates on how it's going ask you how
you feel about it if you want changes to
be made to it they'll make the changes
so they're very receptive it's very
affordable it's a beautiful painting no
reason not to do it right now is a
limited time offer get 30% off your
painting that's right 30% off and free
shipping to get this special offer text
the word matte to 64,000 that's matte to
64,000 text em ATT to 64,000 now for
your daily cancellation today we'll be
canceling voter suppression not the
thing itself but the phrase because as
you know I'm a big fan of voter
suppression but the phrase itself I'm I
think we're gonna cancel you're not
allowed to say it anymore
exhibit a with with crazy Bernie losing
in the primaries so badly his surrogates
are now all over the TV claiming that
his voters are being suppressed that
they would be voting but they can't
because they're suppressed this is it
kind of like a version of when you lose
a game of one-on-one basketball and then
after you already lose you you you you
suddenly come down with a with an
injured ankle that's been injured the
whole time and you say oh yeah my ankle
is actually bothering me for weeks but
yeah it's been pretty been pretty tough
good game but you know my ankle that's
if my ankle was better I probably would
have but good game I'm not taking
anything away from you it's just my with
my ankle it's that that's the issue real
it's probably why I lost a great job now
let's take a look at what voter
suppression looks like what what does
voter suppression mean to a Bernie
Sanders surrogate let's find out first
here's a Alexandria Kaiser Cortez on Fox
a few days ago talking about the awful
suppression that Bernie Sanders voters
faced you did a campaign event at the
University of Michigan had 10,000 people
it was like a rock star status but those
kids did not show up at least if you
look at the numbers I'm just over all
this with this race so so how can you
say the progressive position is still
prevailing nationwide when Joe Biden is
winning so much well I think one thing
that we that isn't being talked about is
the rampant voter suppression in this
country right there in Ann Arbor where
we had that rally those kids were
waiting three hours in line to vote in
Michigan and so when we talk about who's
turning out and who's not turning out we
absolutely just to be clear you're
saying that you think voters didn't get
to vote they wanted to vote in Michigan
absolutely you know obviously there's
also more that we need to do in terms of
turning out youth voters it's we need to
make sure that we're inspiring young
people to turn out but when you do turn
out you should not be waiting three four
seven hours in order to vote ok so
voters are suppressed because they had
to wait in line so what
what was who was suppressing them other
voters the voters were suppressing each
other because they all happen to want to
vote at the same time don't long lines
mean that lots of people are voting
which means that they're not being
suppressed
isn't that an indication that voter
suppression is not happening that's like
saying that long lines at a Star Wars
movie is evidence that people are being
prevented from seeing Star Wars movies
no that makes no sense and the thing is
if there were no lines then aoc would be
up there saying well it's voter
suppression people couldn't make it to
the polls obviously so if there's a lot
of people it's voter suppression if
there's nobody it's voter suppression
that's what we learned
now here's Philip Agnew Bernie Sanders
adviser explaining what voter
suppression means to him the one thing I
will say though is we're we were I was
also in Mississippi and that's where we
saw each other and there were a number
of black colleges who are on spring
break during election day and so we're
up against rampant voter suppression
efforts that are pushing young black
folks out of the voting out of the booth
and not allowing them access to the
franchise and so I think across the
board the Democratic Party has a lot of
work to do to make sure that young black
folks that older black folks have access
to the ballot box and our campaign is
proud to actually be and have been a
part of that but well it's an uphill
battle and it's not just our campaign I
think across the board we've got a lot
of work to do kids were on spring break
that's voter suppression the kids are on
spring break they chose to go on spring
break and so they're being suppressed
they're off in Cancun or whatever or
Pensacola and they're being suppressed
they're on that they're there lounging
on the beach drinking copious amounts of
alcohol I'm being suppressed help me I'm
being suppressed now of course if kids
had class that day we would also be told
that that's voter suppression so classes
no classes voter suppression lines no
lines voter suppression everything is
voter suppression see unless unless this
is what would not by the standards of
AOC or this guy here's what you would
need to do in order to not be
suppressing voters you would need to go
pick up the voters in your arms cradle
them like a baby sing them lullabies and
and carry them into the poll and then
put them down in a comfortable chair in
the voting station and pick up their
hand for them and and with their own
hand press the button that they want to
press that's basically they need in if
they have to expend any energy at all or
do anything for themselves they're being
suppressed but here's an idea here's a
thought
if you want to vote make it a priority
wait in line schedule your time take off
work if you have to if it's that
important it's not like we vote every
day it's something that comes up every
two years so you're telling me it
happens every two years and you can't
figure a way to schedule around it I
don't buy it
we have all this early voting and
everything and we see what happens with
early voting in the primaries people
vote early for a candidate who when it's
time for the actual voting to start he's
already dropped out of the race so but
we're told we need early voting because
we need to give people months or weeks
to vote because they might not have time
on the day of voting to give me a break
you got two years it's that important
you've got two years to just to schedule
time for that day and you can't do it
really you can't give your boss two
years notice tell your boss two years
ahead of time on this particular day I'm
going to be taking off for 30 minutes
you're telling me he's gonna tell you no
you can't do it if if it's not that
important to you that's fine don't vote
see I'm not one of those people that
says how dare you not vote you are you
or not you're betraying your civic duty
now no it's fine you don't want to vote
don't vote perfectly fine in fact if you
have any hesitation about voting if
there's any part of you that thinks I
don't want to vote because I that's I'm
givin up time that I could be spending
watching TV or whatever if that's your
thought process don't vote perfectly
fine it'll be okay in fact it'll be
better without you if it's not really a
priority
I again I am someone who actually I want
to suppress suppress votes I do I want
civics exams for all voters I want the
voters to be taxpayers I want them to be
English speakers I think the number of
people voting should be a fraction of
what it currently is voting is not is
not is not a god-given right for all
people I say it again
voting is not a god-given right for all
people it was never intended to be
that's never how it was supposed to be
set up and even now see when I say that
it sounds like it sounds like heresy in
the modern American mind because most
Americans don't understand the history
of their own system or how it's supposed
to work but even to the person who says
well how could you possibly say that
voting is wonderful everyone should be
voting you don't even believe that
yourself do you think six-year-old
should be voting do you think a rapist
in prison should be voting now there are
some people dumb enough to say that yeah
even they should be voting but most
people would say well no of course not
then okay so that means that means that
you agree that voting is actually not a
right for everyone you agree that there
should be some parameters put in place
you and I are on the same page I'm
saying it's not a universal god-given
right you also believe that whether you
say it or not so since we're on the same
page that there should be parameters put
in place deciding who can vote then what
I'm saying is let's talk about what
those parameters should be you know it
should it just be that we're ruling out
six-year-olds and rapists I mean are
there other kinds of people who maybe
shouldn't be allowed to vote kinds of
people like for example people who
couldn't pass a sixth grade civics exam
or people who are not taxpayers and are
not contributing to the economy that way
or people who can't speak English right
some do do we really need them to be
voting is it better for the country to
have voting from those P
I would say no it's not I would say it's
clearly not better for the country and
if it's not better for the country and
voting is not a god-given universal
right which again we agree it's not then
why are we doing it why are we allowing
it what what what what do you think is
what's like the worst-case scenario if
if we made it so that everyone who votes
can pass a sixth grade civics exam
what's what is the dystopian worst-case
scenario of that oh my gosh now we have
reasonably informed and intelligent
people voting it's the end of the world
like what's what's the what's the
downside I don't even see it I really
don't okay let's go - we're gonna go to
emails here in a second but first here's
possibly the best news you're gonna hear
all day and we could all use some good
news right now using promo code Walsh
you'll get 10% off any daily Y our
membership plan and let me tell you if
you're not a member you are missing all
the best stuff members get our articles
ad free you get access to all of our
live broadcasts you get a show library
you get the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show you get bonus content get
access to the mailbag which we're gonna
get to in a second here plus our new all
access to your gets you into exclusive
live online Q&A discussions with me ben
shapiro and michael knowles Andrew clay
I almost said me and Matt Walsh both of
us are gonna show up together plus their
daily wire writers and special guests
and don't forget you also get the
greatest of all beverage vessels the
leftist tears tumblr all of that plus
10% off when you use promo code Walsh
right now go over to daily wire comm and
become a member today all right so some
emails this say both of these are why
I'm wrong emails so this is from our D
says Matt you're wrong that we should
only listen to the experts on
coronavirus this is exactly the kind of
mentality you'd normally complain about
you're the one who has said many times
you have every right to talk about
something like ADHD and people who
expect you to have an MD to discuss it
are just trying to shut down debate I I
like that version of you better you were
right about that trying to turn the
national conversation into something
that only experts can engage in is
elitist snobbery and it's worse
well you're right Rd I have complained
about the mentality that says that you
should have to present your resume
before engaging in a conversation about
anything I reject the idea that you have
to be a certified experts to have an
opinion on any subject but I also think
that if we're in the middle of a crisis
and that crisis involves a very specific
scientific phenomenon like a virus then
you should have a real understanding of
viruses in a very firm base of knowledge
and some experience in the field if
you're going to make public
pronouncements about the virus and its
relative threat to the public and so on
so those two positions of mine are not
in conflict and I really don't think it
should be controversial all I'm saying
is you should know what you're talking
about if you're if you're making
statements about something like a
pandemic and especially if you're if
you're making explicit or implicit
recommendations to other people about
how seriously they should or should not
take it then you should know what you're
talking about like that I can't believe
that you're not the only email like this
how could anyone disagree but people do
I'm saying no what you're talking about
people say well how dare you I don't
think you should know what you're
talking about at all if we go back to
the voting thing it's like this people
think it's it's it's good to have
ignorant morons
you know chiming in it's it's not now
imagine if somebody was diagnosed with
cancer do you think it would be
responsible and reasonable if I were to
come along with no experience in n
Kotlin in oncology and no expertise and
you know no medical degree or anything
with very little understanding of how
cancer works and all the same if I were
to come to that person and dispense
confident advice on the types of
treatment they should receive and how
serious they should take their diagnosis
would that be reasonable for me to do
would that be responsible would you
encourage that and with the person with
cancer be an elitist snob for saying to
me you know what I'm gonna listen to the
doctors on this so you know maybe you
should pipe down
no III think pretty clearly and does
that mean that I should never say
anything about cancer does that mean
that there are no issues related to
cancer that I could possibly have
anything valuable to say about no it
just means that on the specific medical
and scientific questions I should leave
it to the people who understand the
questions and the answers better than I
do again that should not be
controversial
you mentioned ADHD you're right I have
many opinions about that I have no
problem sharing them but my opinions
have little to do with the neurological
or medical issues involved now if under
if a neurologist comes along and tells
me about the differences in brain scans
between ADHD people and people without
ADHD I'll listen you know I'm not gonna
argue with them they know that better
than I do I haven't really studied the
issue that much at least the
neurological piece of it and if a doctor
wants to tell me about the diagnostic
criteria for 88 ADHD you know if I'm
making statements about that and a
doctor says you're wrong here's the the
real criteria okay I'll listen to that
too
I'm not gonna pretend to know more than
the doctor or the neurologist in their
fields but my point about ADHD is that
even though there are diagnostic
criteria and even if you can see it in a
brain scan which for my reading actually
in many cases you can't but again I'll
defer to the experts on that my point is
that it doesn't prove that the thing is
actually a disorder it doesn't prove
that the people who have ADHD aren't
supposed to be that way because what the
doctors are saying about the ADHD kid is
not just he exhibits these traits and he
has this and not going on in his brain
what they're saying is he's not supposed
to be this way we have to use drugs to
change him a kid is not supposed to act
this way and think this way and behave
this way and so we must treat it like a
disease and try to change it and that I
submit is not a medical opinion that is
an opinion about how humans are supposed
to be which is a philosophical opinion
it's a very deep philosophical opinion
the question if I were to ask you how is
a human supposed to be what is a human's
how is a human supposed to think now I'm
not even sure
that's an answerable question but if it
is an answerable question it's not
answerable just to doctors I think we
all have an equal shot at taking a crack
at that one and getting it right because
we're all people and we all have
experience being human beings now I say
that the child with ADHD is supposed to
be that way
I say that's his personality and if it
doesn't if it's if it interferes at
school
well that's more a statement about flaws
in the school system than it is a
statement about flaws in him so my
opinion is not medical not scientific
all the science in the world's not gonna
change my mind because it's irrelevant
to the point that's not the point I'm
making it would be like if I was giving
my view on the meaning of life and you
were to say oh yeah you're not even a
scientist so what but why would a
scientist have any greater insight into
the meaning of life that anyone else now
they might be able to tell me a lot of
scientific facts about the nature of
life fine but as far as its meaning its
purpose who cares if you're scientist or
not you're not gonna any better chance
at being right on that than anyone else
would and so those are the differences
finally is this from Cody says big fan
of the show but you're wrong in regards
to price gouging the attached link does
a concise yet thorough job of explaining
why this is not a bad thing also it is
troubling that you express more concern
with an individual selling an item to
willing buyers at an agreed-upon price
as opposed to the state literally taking
what was rightfully his property at
point of gun although I am an extreme
Liberty lover and anarcho-capitalist I
don't doubt that you also support
individual sovereignty although maybe
not to the same degree it is important
in times like this for us to not allow
fear to cause us to turn a blind eye at
tyranny which is exactly what occurred
when the aforementioned man had his
property seized and then Cody attaches a
link with a 10-page document Cody I
haven't read your link yet I admit I
will but of course there is a there's
there's a difference I think between
saying people have the right to price
gouge and saying that people are right
to price gouge now you seem to be making
the latter case that it's the right
thing to do now
or maybe I'm wrong but we're making the
case but and and and maybe the article
that you're sending we'll get into this
but if you want to tell me that there
are situations where so-called price
gouging by stores in an emergency or
disaster is necessary and maybe in some
cases actually good then I might agree
you know you could are I could I could
see how that might be the case you could
argue plausibly that a store increasing
prices on a necessary item in a time of
emergency will ensure that it's
available to more people so if there's a
you know shortage of clean healthy water
in a disaster and you've got a store
with these big gallon jugs of water for
98 cents a piece well what's gonna
happen the first few people that come in
are gonna clean the whole place out and
get more water than they need and then
they're gonna be other people who get no
water
and so maybe price gouging and I'm
totally I don't even know if this is the
argument in the link I'm just saying
this is an argument I could see for
price catch but what if you raise the
price then it's gonna mean that few that
people are not going to buy as much are
more likely to buy only what they need
and then that's gonna leave some more
for those who need it and then we're
spreading out spreading the wealth you
know to use an unfortunate phrase okay
and so I could see that that's not what
happened here this was most assuredly
not something that was done to ensure
that more people would have access to
the thing that this guy bought this was
a guy who bought up all the hand
sanitizer you know in the stores in his
state and surrounding states he went
around about like 17,000 boxes of hands
or 17,000 things of hand hand sanitizer
bought them all up so that he could
resell them and sometimes it had prices
that were you know like for the $70 like
ten times what they would cost in the
store now here's the point
this dude was doing exactly the thing
that the defenders of price gouging say
we need to protect against you see what
I'm saying this the kind of good price
gouging that arguably a store could do
would be done exactly to stop this guy
from doing what he did which tells me
that this is the bad kind of price
gouging we're talking about for sure
um you know let's think about what if
this was a really necessary item I think
the only argument you could actually
make against what the state did in this
case by confiscating the hand sanitizer
from this guy is is to say that well
it's not really a necessary item because
you know you have soap soap it's
actually better to wash your hands with
than that hand send it so it's not like
if people don't hand sanitizer they
can't wash their hands if they have soap
they still can so you could argue it's
not a necessary item so that what the
state did was was exorbitant okay maybe
that's the case but are there situations
where the state would be correct in
responding the way they did
is this a power or authority that in
theory they should have I would say yes
and for this reason imagine ifs and this
is not not necessarily a far-fetched
hypothetical what if somebody goes
around during a shortage during an
emergency buys up all the baby formula
in in all the stores and surrounding
areas hoards the mall form so it doesn't
even have a baby himself and then
resells it for exorbitant prices well
now you've got a situation where many
families are gonna need formula you know
you got mothers who don't breastfeed or
can't breastfeed for one reason or
another they've already stopped
breastfeeding and now they don't produce
milk anymore they need that formula for
their infants and maybe they can't
afford it at what it's being sold by the
price gouging what do we do do we throw
up our hands and say well finders
keepers sorry babies you're out of luck
guess you'll have to starve to death no
I I don't think that I don't think we
say well we don't want to infringe on
this guy's Liberty to buy all the baby
formula and and become a millionaire off
of it
we don't wanna I don't want any fringe
on that right so we're just gonna let
the babies die it seems clear that in
that case if you argued against state
involvement you would be putting his
supposed liberties his suppose right to
buy whatever he wants and sell whatever
he wants without restriction in every
situation over the needs of families to
feed their children and the rights of
babies to not starve to death
and this is exactly where libertarianism
breaks down him
piñon because a write like the right to
buy and sell stuff is is important of
course but you would want to make it
sacrosanct right where you would say
that nothing could ever be a good enough
reason to infringe on that right and I
simply disagree I think that there are
times when the right to buy and sell
stuff has to be subordinated to other
rights so the way I would break this
down I guess is that in situations like
this if somebody is buying up necessary
items that the community needs really
needs then the state ought to step in in
situations like that you know not under
normal circumstances and I think that
hand sanitizer is a relatively
superfluous thing because you don't need
it because you have soap so probably I
would agree with you the state was wrong
in this case but I'm not gonna make a
blanket statement that they that it
would be always be wrong for them to do
this because as I said I could certainly
see situations where I think for the
state not to get involved would be
madness so that's where I would leave
that but you're right I'm not an
anarcho-capitalist myself so maybe it's
not surprising I have this view thank
you for watching everybody thank you for
listening be safe out there
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]